السلام عليكم ورحمه الله من الجزيره وقدم
لكم موجزه الاخبار عقد الرئيسان الامريكيو
جو بايدن والاكرانيه
في البيت الابيض وكشف بعيد عن تقديم
المساعدات الاوكرانيه بقيمه مليار
و850 مليون دولار تشمل منظومه
الروسي الروسيه
لوقف الحرب ولا رغبه لديه في السلام
خطابه
الرئيس الاوكراني بالتسريع المساعدات
الامريكيه لبلاده لتحقيق النصر في الحرب
على روسيا وقال ان الجيش الاوكرانيه لن
يستسلم ابدا وسيواصل الدفاع عن اوكرانيا
اقرت وزاره الدفاع الاوكرانيه ان القوات
الروسيه استطعت ان تؤمن لنفسها موطئه
بحسب تعبيرها في مدينه باخ موت شرقيه
اوكرانيا وقالت السلطات الاوكرانيه ان
الوضع في جبهه في غايه الصعوبه قال الرئيس
الروسي فلاديمر بوتين خلال الاجتماع
اهدافها العسكريه في اوكرانيا وتحافظ على
توازن الرد
النووي الذي قال بشانه انه اساسه
الاستقرار في العالم
من جهته قال وزير الدفاع الروسي سر جي شوي
يقول ان الجيش الروسيه نشر انواعا جديده
ومتطوره من الصواريخ البحريه والبالستيه
مثلي منظومه صواريخ تصيركن وسارما تل
عابره للقارات
وفي بيجين اجرا الرئيس الصيني يشيجن
مع مناورات عسكريه المشتركه بين القوات
البحريه الصينيه والروسيه وقد اكد الرئيس
الصيني وعلى تطويل الشراكه مع موسكو كخيار
نص استراتيجيين طويل العمر من جهته قلم
ادفيديف انه بحث
اوكرانيا
الاستراتيجيه بلا حدود بين البلدين
اعلن الهلال الاحمر الفلسطيني واستشهاد
شاب فلسطيني واصابه 22 في مواجهات مع
القوات الاحتلال في منطقه الشرقيه من
مدينه نابلس بالضفه الغربيه المحتله وكانت
قوه كبيره من جيش الاحتلال اقتحمت المنطقه
لتامين اقتحام المستوطنين قبر يوسف وسطا
بلا عنوان عنيفه
قررت اسرائيل واحتجاز جثمان الاسير
الفلسطيني ناصر ابو حميد وعدم تسليمه
لاهله بعد استشهاده نتيجه تدهور حالته
الصحيه وقال وزير الدفاع الاسرائيلي
بالنيس ان القراره ياتي لضروره تتعلق
بمفاوضات صفقات التبادل الاسرى وقد لقاها
القرار الاسرائيلي التمديدا فلسطينيا وسط
دعوات لتحرك الدوله
اشكركم على متابعه المدرس لما كنتم طابت
اوقاتكم بكل خير
[موسيقى]